a group of 80 democrats in congress
proposes the creation of a federal body
to combat climate change also
those democrats say that the project would
stimulate the economy but not all
agree
on the leader of the democrats in
senator charles schumer says that the  plan
would help create millions of jobs the
body would work on
clean energy projects as well as help
prevent wildfires and other
projects to improve the
environment democrats say
wildfires heat waves hurricanes and
other storms are increasing  worse
because of global warming and that it is
necessary to combat these problems
immediately they want the
funds for the creation of the new federal body to
be approved as part of
the infrastructure package
but republicans like senator
mitch mcconnell say that the last thing
the country needs  is more spending by
the government that will require an ing  Less
in taxes Republicans say that
the last stimulus package approved
by the Democrats because of the
pandemic is causing inflation and
also a shortage of workers and they
say that this new project would worsen
that situation reporting in washington
alexandra limón